bienvenidos a en 5 minutos donde
intentamos explicar de manera sencilla
asuntos complicados la guerra en ucrania
ha puesto los ojos del mundo sobre rusia
y ha planteado preguntas sobre la
influencia que este país ejerce en
distintas regiones del planeta desde la
llegada de vladimir putin al poder hace
más de dos décadas uno de sus
principales objetivos ha sido devolver a
rusia su estatus de gran potencia
mundial y américa latina' no se ha
quedado fuera de sus planes en el marco
del conflicto por el temor de rusia de
que ucrania se una a la alianza militar
de la otan mosco ha buscado fortalecer
su influencia en esta región por su
cercanía geográfica y política a eeuu
que tantas la influencia económica de
rusia en américa latina y que
acercamientos ha habido tras el
estallido de la guerra veamos el plano
económico uno de los pilares de la
relación comercial entre rusia y américa
latina' se creó tras la anexión de
crimea en 2014 tras las sanciones que le
impuso la unión europea al kremlin tuvo
que mirar hacia otros lados para
conseguir alimentos que antes se
encontraba en países como españa y es
por ello que comenzó a gran parte de sus
frutas verduras y carne de países como
uruguay argentina o brasil entre tanto
las exportaciones de rusia hacia las
regiones son principalmente de petróleo
fertilizantes aluminio hierro carbón y
trigo pero la presencia de rusia en
américa latina no es tan fuerte como se
creería para hacernos una idea según la
universidad de harvard en 2019 américa
latina' exportó a rusia productos por
valor de 5 mil millones de dólares
mientras que las exportaciones a eeuu
fueron de 66 mil millones de dólares y a
china de
119 mil millones de dólares rusia cuenta
con aliados como venezuela aunque éste
no le suponga grandes entradas
económicas con su economía devastada el
gobierno venezolano ha recurrido
reiteradamente de rusia en búsqueda de
apoyo en 2018 rusia ha invertido 6 mil
millones de dólares en el país y ha
adquirido buena parte de las empresas
petroleras nacionales a la vez que
compra buena parte de su crudo y
contrario a lo que se creería venezuela
no es el principal socio comercial
en américa latina argentina brasil y
méxico son los países que más comercian
con el país euroasiático
en cuanto a las armas rusas venezuela
fue el quinto comprador hasta el inicio
de la crisis económica otras naciones
que han comprado grandes arsenales a
rusia son en perú méxico argentina
brasil colombia o uruguay pasamos ahora
a la política un plano en el que los
intentos de rusia de posicionarse en
américa latina son mucho más notorios
desde el estallido de la crisis en
ucrania el kremlin ha buscado
fortalecerse en países tradicionalmente
aliados a eeuu como argentina y brasil
así como con antiguos socios de la unión
soviética en enero putin invitó al
presidente argentino alberto fernández a
moscú en la cita fernández manifestó que
sus países debería convertirse en la
puerta de entrada de rusia a américa
latina' y prometió reducir la
dependencia de su país de eeuu
declaraciones que no pasaron
desapercibidas en la región el político
argentino
también agradeció el apoyo que rusia
brindó a argentina durante la pandemia y
es que mientras otras grandes potencias
acaparaban dosis de las vacunas
moscú buscó que su vacuna sputnik 5
fuera la primera en llegar a varios
países latinoamericanos entre ellos
también estuvieron bolivia nicaragua
paraguay y venezuela también el
presidente brasileño jair bolsonaro
quien se ha distanciado de washington
desde la llegada al poder de joe biden
acudió a una cita con putin en el
kremlin lo hizo pocos días antes de que
iniciara la guerra en ucrania y llegó
incluso a desautorizar públicamente a su
vicepresidente hamilton moray por
condenar la invasión por otro lado está
la relación con cuba y venezuela- de
esta han surgido preocupaciones por un
posible despliegue militar de moscú como
respuesta a la presencia de la otan y
eeuu en europa y cada vez más cerca a
las fronteras rusas esto luego de que el
vice ministro de exteriores ruso dijera
que no se descartaba ninguna cuando se
le preguntó sobre la posibilidad de que
desplegará infraestructura militar en
esos países luego en lo que se consideró
como un momento determinante para medir
la influencia de rusia en la región tras
el ataque a ucrania bolivia nicaragua y
cuba se abstuvieron al votar una
resolución de la asamblea general de las
naciones unidas que condenaba la
invasión venezuela no votó mientras que
argentina y brasil cuya postura estuvo
en duda finalmente votaron para rechazar
la a pesar de un rechazo casi
generalizado en occidente a sus acciones
el gigante euroasiático se sigue
mostrando determinado a no quedar
relegado como potencia mundial y abrirse
campo entre las esferas de dominio de
sus rivales si les sirvió el vídeo para
entender el alcance de la influencia de
rusia en américa latina' los esperamos
en otro episodio de cinco minutos en
france 24 y france 24 puntocom